I'm very proud of this sketch you know
because like when we first who in the
world could that be let's find out
hello there reject nation
Greg Alva here John Humphrey the
self-indulgence continues with Greg and
John reacting to other people reacting
to our [ __ ] and today comes from Tyrone
Magnus Tyrone was featured in our
Avengers and game sketch he had a brief
little moment but he did not know the
details well when I literally emailed
him saying like I need you to do this
this and it's gonna lead into a montage
that's all he knew so it didn't really
know much about it once it was up he
sent me a test text asking if he could
do it I said no we don't do no I will
hit it includes copyrighted content and
I will have this video blog so here we
are talk a little bit more about it and
funny little moment happened you might
have seen our reaction or knee to Lake
to the party's reaction of this but
Tyrone's is when I'm very much looking
forward to its Tyrone Magnus man I
wasn't even expecting him to want to do
a reaction to it I was ashamed he is his
whole reactions just gonna be him
apologize yeah
it sure is too long get to it get to it
on man get to it I can't scrub this
video skip to this you should say at the
beginning of every video
[Music]
Johnny which I appreciate
got a comment today go out tie red
sports remind me that I said that yes we
did yes we do
yes we did
we will not acknowledge brain off in a
trailer because we are jealous and
should have not acknowledged us 87 there
is no it's just nice to watch it great
because of us
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you're watching these I get what people
love that Tyrone neck
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Applause]
ah sting thanks and make sure all of you
get over there and you make sure you
follow oh thanks I did see that's called
yeah wow that's fun the great tyrone
magnus saw one of our skinny and he left
it seems like that when we show this
sketch to people the biggest laughs come
from two parts the aqus on part yes and
when i say yes yeah I mean seem to be
the two biggest moments like from late
to the party that tie rods and the few
people we've shown it to in person yeah
called subverting expectations like that
that makes me happy it was cool to get
Tyrone to be game for this yeah it's
funny cuz I brought seven late to the
party one I told Tyrone the wrong line
for the Doctor Strange moment and he
sent over the footage already and I
tried getting him to resend the footage
to do the proper quote but instead we
just use it to our advantage when the
when it says like isn't the line dr.
strange says there was no other way lazy
ass reaction yes it was a chance to make
another meta joke so it was like it's
actually cool the time room isn't
centered over I'll have a chance to
insert a quick little nugget that you
can just pause really quick you know cuz
possibles make videos even more fun yeah
where you save as voice yes thank you
I forgot all about it Tyrone does this
thing where like he does it for Thanos
or venom we will eat both of your arms
and then both of your legs and then we
will eat your face bright off of your
head
you will be this on this legless
faceless thing where he'll like redub
the lines not doing an impersonation of
them he's just using his voice deepest
register but it works like that he's
like doing a person I don't know if he's
going for an impression I'm like it
sounds like Tyrone's voice but it works
I guess he's like auditioning his own
voice or putting it out there that you
could use my voice and almost anything
they want to do like a demo yeah voice
acting it's like my voice would a word
for Thanos is what a word for veteran
could play Thanos or Vicki could do
whatever what cuz of that boys would be
the buffest Batman it was fun watching
his reaction man yeah it's very
rewarding to make Tyrone smile yeah this
is to have our silliness amused this man
makes me happy
it makes me very happy it's fun because
we've done sketches before that dumb
play before a reaction and some of them
have done pretty well then a lot of
times are really on the lower view side
count even though people watch them they
love them they like to do like the
little micro sketches before a reaction
where just like a little fun intro there
were those cool issues like micro
sketches and they evolved into like
actual sketches and sketches yeah actual
sketches and it was the cool chance to
get Porton people to see our actual
sketches and a way to do that with the
intros was a way to kind of stand out
from other reaction channels in a market
that has so many reaction channels true
yeah that we're not lazy yeah it's like
even though we do all the commentary and
everything like that it's cool to show
that we can also make some stuff too
and what I'm really proud about this
sketch specifically is it's kind of a
celebration of all things because a big
part of what's made reaction channels so
big is doing stuff like The Avengers you
know this is the culmination movie I
felt like would be a cool way to do a
culmination of the reactors that we've
come to know we don't know all them but
the ones that we've come to know like
tyro and I'm Dante okay there's a couple
that we missed but the feature and
there's a couple that I hit out that
just couldn't do it his so the sketch
was specifically designed for people who
are fans of our
channel and for people who are fans of
the reactor world in general so I'm
really proud of it you know I feel like
if you're not you might not you probably
don't care for it you know like it's
this plain and simple like you
centerpiece yeah not make a lot of sense
yeah if you're not a fan of us in
general if you're not a fan of the
reactor or especially the ones featured
in here you just won't care for it which
is fine but for the ones who are
featured in if you are those people that
we are specifically made this for I feel
like there's been a pretty really
positive responsibility yeah yeah so
we're really happy about it man it's our
most liked video we've had all year so
I'm really happy now look out for 20
minutes sketching from the end game
movie review yeah let's skip to 35 nah
man we want to bring it back to the
shorty down the sketches at this point
but thank you guys for watching thanks
Tyrone for checking this video out I
hope when you do come out to LA we do
get a kick it homey yeah man I was with
him when Tom Holland recognized him I
know do all these sketches references
specific scene because the spider-verse
there's so many of you possibly they
wanna catch it and that's how I rise to
meet you well clearly you need to get in
the spandex for the next sketch and
that'll be your big office oh man maybe
you can get into James Gunn's Suicide
Squad yeah that's what I want man
all right guys well you can subscribe to
the reject nation click that
notification bell and I don't know if
you've heard of Tyrone but you should go
check out his channel it's pretty
popular and check us on patreon TV show
reactions QAS music video coverage love
to have you come a picture object to die